[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv 78 7 8
sociétés un peu particulier ce soir pour
des raisons techniques le sujet de ce
soir le manque de médecins généralistes
zone d'intervention prioritaire zone
d'action complémentaires les yvelines
sont comme de nombreux territoires
touchés par des difficultés pour les
habitants à se soigner une nouvelle
tendance semble pourtant émerger la
hausse de créations de maisons santé est
ce une réalité est une solution dans pas
avec nos invités françois mort tous une
sorte bons soins d'un pigiste président
de 50 ans domine en charge de la santé
et maire de guyancourt et en visio
pauline chine au cours de fouilles
lefebvre pardon bonsoir
montois geass président du département
de ville en charge de la ruralité farid
adlani bonsoir bonsoir vice président de
la région ile de france en charge de la
santé laurent de bastard bonsoir mon
choix vice président de l'ordre des
médecins des yvelines et nicolas d'un
team bon soir bonsoir vous êtes le maire
de la verrière je voudrais commencer
avec vous madame adlani
au mesnil s'amener en août une maison de
santé a ouvert la région investissent
170000 euros pour cette maison de santé
c'est pourtant pas une compétence de la
région la santé
absolument la région n'est pas là la
santé n'est pas une compétence de la
région pour autant la région est
pleinement engagée et mobilisée pour
lutter contre la désertification
médicale parce que comme vous le savez
la l'île de france et le premier désert
médical en france avec des difficultés
pour les mères et je suis je vois qu'il
ya des maires qui sont connectés que
c'est souvent les merdes et nous voir la
région n'était pas identifié comme un
partenaire financier aujourd'hui elle
est de plus en plus on a vu la région se
mobiliser lors de cette crise qu vide
nous voilà mobile art et juan su
mobiliser aussi pour financer eh bien tu
es médecin qui s'implantent dans des
zones qui en ont besoin en sachant que
la région finance des équipes
pluridisciplinaires puisque la le nouvel
exercice d des médecins qui sont souvent
des femmes ce qu'il ya une féminisation
de la profession on voit qu'elles
veulent travailler ensemble avec
plusieurs disciplines que ce soit des
médecins généralistes du paramédical des
vols staff et les dossiers et donc la
région finance pour ce qui structure
avec des financements qui sont
essentiels pour et bien l'implantation
du médecin et de paramédics alors la
grèce a classé en 2018 de ville en zone
d'intervention prioritaire et d'actions
complémentaires la zone d'intervention
prioritaire c'est pour les territoires
caractérisée par un faible niveau
d'accessibilité aux soins les zones
d'actions complémentaires sont moins
impactés mais la situation peut se
détériorer dans les yvelines 118
communes sont tendus 103 en zac sur 259
communes que compte le département ça
paraît énorme docteur laurent de bastard
ils sont et nombreuses communes qui sont
en territoire vooren comme ç'avait
département est différente avec une
pince d'azur band très peu ran et même
sur neil les zones urbaines on sait que
bords de seine une commune du manque de
médecins ou encore vie et c'est assez
même si les noms la chance d'avoir
l'université de médecine de
saint quentin qui on sait que les jeux
de médecins s'installent
préférentiellement où ils ont étudié
l'histoire on voit que les gars 6 mais
si j'y suis allé mais ça ne lui choisir
et que un
plaisir et non une activité salariée une
activité libérale parce qu'ils ont des
avantages sont morts et congés payés et
de misère afin d'aller lire et à une
proportion de femmes qui ont des enfants
avec un peu d'eau dp leurs enfants
attendaient et que je m'étais arrêté qui
est jusqu'à maintenant et pendant un an
100 est donc là les difficultés que les
médecins peuvent rentrer pour de récents
font que pius installa son talent
prometteur vous pourrez pêcher
aujourd'hui la note négative alors si
avec les 1500 euros pour que les
pouvoirs publics à la fois qui peut
mieux le département finance il ya des
maisons des structures nous il y avait
en son propre kit esthétique à 60 ans
mais avec difficulté de trouver les 5 c
une extension est aussi médecin via yen
qui a ne restent pas parce que
l'exercice est compliquée et à affaler
chargé de l'extra team les horaires et
affront que on a peut-être un gros vous
avez vu peut-être les u11 de décret qui
à mes fins ni l'autre plusieurs sont en
que normalement il va y avoir un peu
plus avec son équipement est fort mais
non il faut une dizaine d'années on est
restreinte sait pas dans l'immédiat que
la la pénurie il est sympa
alors parmi les communes classées en
zone d'intervention prioritaire sur
saint quentin en yvelines il y attrape
et la verrière nicolas dainville vous
êtes le maire de cette commune votre
site internet ne recense aucun médecin
généraliste est ce que la maison de
santé pour être une solution pour la
commune
mais écoutez c'est vrai qu'on a une
vraie pénurie de médecins en france en a
310 médecin cent mille habitants c'est
100 de moi par exemple qu'en allemagne
en outre notre voisin un partenaire il
ya la verrière on a effectivement 0
médecin 0 médecin pour une commune de
skimming 6500 habitants donc sacré ddd
vraiment une vraie gêne vrai handicap
pour beaucoup de patients beaucoup
d'habitants et donc effectivement on se
mobilise avec le département et je salue
pauline bino pour le faire sur cette
question d'aimer
alors problèmes rénaux pour le faible
quand on regarde les communes
particulièrement touchées par ce manque
de médecins ce sont des petites communes
en zones rurales
oui c'est ainsi une problématique qu'on
avait identifiées au début du dernier
mandat au cours des assises de la
ruralité et on avait travaillé avec de
nombreux partenaires pour pour justement
favoriser la construction de structures
pour accueillir ces médecins ou de
maison médicale et
je me souviens très bien comme le
souligne laurent de bastard qu'on nous
avait dit à l'époque que les médecins
allaient pas spontanément me poser leur
plaque dans un département parce qu'il
était sympathique jolie et rural mais
parce que le département parce que c'est
le médecin avait déjà exercé ou a pris à
cet endroit là on fait des stages donc
nous on a monté un dispositif alors
d'abord un des préalables c'est d'avoir
un bébé médecin généraliste au démarrage
du projet ensuite on a des structures on
essaie d'avoir des médecins qu'ils
soient maîtres de stage pour qu'ils
accueillent des jeunes et qui leur donne
envie de exercez parce qu'il n'ya pas
que la structure les structures c'est un
vrai plus et un vrai outil au service
des médecins et de nos populations
mais il faut les faire venir ses
médecins et donc pour qu'ils viennent là
où ils ont appris on essaye de favoriser
la formation des maîtres de stage et de
soulager leurs charges administratives
en tout cas pendant les premières années
de fonctionnement de la maison médicale
avec une aide au secrétariat dans ces
maisons médicales donc ce dispositif en
a mis en place au cours du mandat
précédent il a permis il va permettre la
construction de la mise en place de 22
maisons médicales et il aura mobilisé
cinquante neuf médecins généralistes 230
professionnels de santé et 59
généraliste donc ça résout pas le
problème en lames ce que veut le
problème il est important en revanche ça
peut enrayer la fuite de certains
médecins notamment en permettant à des
médecins proches de la retraite de
maintenir leur activité un peu plus
longtemps parce qu'ils ont ces
structures et puis de relance dynamique
d'accueil parce qu'on a des bocaux pour
accueillir des jeunes médecins
françois me retombe on a parlé des iep
il ya ces communes sur 50 ans de bîmes
qui sont en sac coignard hui en cours
dont vous êtes le maire magny les
hameaux mance pas plaisir villepreux est
ce que c'est une situation qui inquiète
l'agglomération aussi alors j'ai envie
de dire qui s'il ya bien un sujet qui
nous rassemble tous et nicolas david ici
présents mancera témoins probablement
c'est cette vigilance que nous vont tout
savoir quel que soit notre statut alors
bien évidemment il ya des disparités sur
saint quentin en yvelines entre la
verrière il avait cité par exemple et
d'autres villes lui en cours j'ai envie
de dire dans deux à mi chemin quelque
part et d'autres communes mieux doté en
offre de santé il y à des disparités
mais nous sommes tous concernés par ce
problème puisque nous savons que par
exemple notre population est en train de
vieillir donc nous devons anticiper
cette donnée alors saint quentin en
yvelines s'est totalement inscrit dans
cette anticipation avec la signature par
exemple du contrat local de santé dès
2018 un outil qui permet aussi
d'objectiver les choses au travers du
train tableau de bord santé que nous
avons publiée en 2020 et j'ai envie de
dire depuis le début de ce dernier
mandat une rencontre individuelle avec
l'ensemble des maires pour essayer
d'accompagner au mieux en fonction des
besoins sur leur territoire alors
certains avides et ont dû nous quitter
en raison du retard pris au moment de la
prise d'antenne chaque semaine on
interroge nos téléspectateurs cette
semaine c'était sur le ressenti par
rapport à la prise de rendez-vous
61% au retour d'entre eux ont des
difficultés à prendre rendez-vous dans
les mines chez les généralistes comme
les spécialistes françois morton c'est
une réponse qui vous étonne alors pas
vraiment encore une fois en tenant
compte des disparités bien en bien
entendu
saint quentin en yvelines a fait le
choix
m'excuserai sur cette image un peu
triviale mais d'aller à la fois avec de
l'artillerie lourde et je pense
notamment à la à l'accompagnement dans
la création des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires qui sont des
structures absolument nécessaire je
crois que que tout le monde est d'accord
et que ce soit le département ou la
région d'ailleurs qui nous en a parlé on
doit être complémentaire dans ces
accompagnements là mais on doit aussi
faire dans la dentelle la dentelle
qu'est ce que c'est c'est d'aller encore
une fois au plus au plus proche des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
parce que certes il peut y avoir des
disparités difficulté de trouver un
généraliste c'est évident plus ou moins
compliquées en fonction du territoire et
le tableau de bord nous dit par exemple
que sur l'offre de spécialistes saint
quentin c'est plutôt pas mal voilà et en
même temps discutant avec les médecins
mais j'y reviendrai peut-être tout à
l'heure en discutant avec les médecins
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya aussi un
changement de population chez les
médecins et qu' il nous parle beaucoup
par exemple de leurs cadres non
seulement professionnelle mais aussi de
leur cadre de vie et c'est pour ça qu'on
doit être très vigilant aussi sur
l'attractivité de notre territoire pas
simplement sur les heurs professionnels
mais aussi sur toutes les autres heures
nicolas dainville sur la deux
de la verrière phares dont il ya le site
mgen il ya donc des professionnels de
santé qui se rendent sur votre ville
est-ce que vous avez du mal à les garder
peut-être en libéral aller débaucher
presque
d'écouté effectivement c'est un rappeur
un paradoxe c'est qu'on a un hôpital
d'alger 2 qui excelle dans son domaine
mais on a on n'a pas de médecin alors on
a répondu à un appel à projet de la rs
l'agencé régionale de santé pour
justement essayer d'avoir des médecins
ville hôpital avec une partie de leur
activité qui sera consacré à la mgen et
puis une autre à à nos habitants mais on
a encore une fois du mal à recruter ces
professionnels
pour ce mandat ce sont 7 millions qui
ont été débloqués pour la santé est ce
que ce seront sept millions que pour des
maisons de santé est ce que vous êtes
sollicité sur d'autres projets
oui alors d'abord pour vous donner un
chiffre vous parlez de 7 millions pour
les maisons de santé mais moi je vais
vous en donner un outre ces 1 37 million
qui qui ont été octroyés depuis le début
de la mandature depuis 2016 pour 243
structures de santé dont il voulait on
parle beaucoup de la rs et vous avez
parlé est très justement de ce zonage
qui est établie par la rs à dire que
concrètement les rays ni quelles sont
les zones qui sont sous dotées voire pas
dotée du tout et donc ils sont des zones
prioritaires or la région de france elle
prend le pari autrement c'est que autant
la rs fait un constat un instant t et va
cartographier à un instant t figé cette
cartographie nous nous avons choisi
délibérément de travailler avec les
maires donc moi je fais un appel à
monsieur le maire effectivement s'il a
donc c'est il est dans une situation
difficile moi je rencontre souvent les
mères qui viennent me voir par
anticipation delà de la désertification
de leur ville et pour m'expliquer c'est
à dire que je vois des mères qui me
disent vous savez moi dans deux trois
ans eh bien j'ai de temps de médecins
généralistes qui ont entre soit 63 ans
et donc j'en aurai plus dans quelques
dans un angle de j'ai pu le médecin
généraliste donc l'air pour la rs est
pas une zone d' de désert médical or
dans deux dans quelques années ça en
étant donc nous on anticipe cette
désertification médicale du 6 36
millions d'euros donc est ce qu on fait
donc avec les maires et qu'on travaille
en outre à ce que les écoles avec la
région de france à la compétence de tous
les paramédicaux et donc elles financent
les infirmiers les aides-soignants les
kinés les sages femmes c'est toute
formation que la région ile-de-france
finances et on voit aussi cette
complémentarité nous demandent à la rs6
on a eu des on a des échanges avec la rs
régulièrement et c'est vrai que
l'activité partagé fait partie des
pistes d'amélioration du réflexion qu un
soignant un médecin en particulier peut
avoir cette activité de travailler en
tant que salarié dans un hôpital mais
avoir une activité en libéral et donc
souvent appuyés avec les merdes que les
maires dans cette aussi esprit
d'aménagement de leur de leur ville eh
bien nous on a intégré que dans
l'aménagement du territoire dans
l'aménagement de la ville ne peut y
avoir sur des opérations immobilières en
pied d'immeuble et bien des des cabinets
médicaux vous disiez vous évoqué le cas
d'une structure à 160000 euros mais
c'est du fonctionnement c'est de
l'investissement c'est de la
sécurisation c'est aussi des bourses
pour des étudiants
qui n'est par exemple ou sage-femme et
on leur donne une bourse pour
s'installer dans les zones désertes sous
dotées poète il ils sont payés pendant
leurs études ils ont cette bourse et en
contrepartie ils doivent s'installer
tant d'années trois quatre ans en
fonction du nombre d'années qu'on était
en plus financé par la région pour
permettre justement qui est un maillage
territorial
parce que il faut absolument
accompagner l'évolution est dans cette
évolution je voudrais pas être trop long
mais dans cette évolution vous parlais
tout à l'heure des rendez vous et des
rendez vous trop long et on a des on
voit bien que c'est vraiment la
problématique faute de médecins c'est le
cas de monsieur le maire j'en suis sûr
faute de médecin il ya les citoyens et
bien se retourne vers les urgences est
donc un engorgement des urgences
derrière et hawx est vraiment une
spirale infernale et on voit bien que
l'hôpital est déjà en tension et en
période de crise on l'a bien on l'a bien
vu donc il ya aussi tout ce travail là
d'accompagnement donc la région ile de
france est pleinement mobilisée même si
elle n'a pas la compétence ce qui leur
région ile de france avec valérie
pécresse nous n'avons pas n'avions pas à
financer ses 243 structure je peux vous
dire que des structures miens ne serait
pas ne serait pas monté et enfin et pour
terminer il s'agit pas seulement de de
financer des murs parce que avoir des
cabinets médicaux et s'ils sont vivants
et bien c'est pas l'objectif c'est ce
que faisait l'ancienne mandature nous on
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille avec les
maires parce que le maire va avoir et
bien 7 7 pro activité de 32,2 d'avoir
des des médecins d'intégrer des médecins
est de permettre à un écosystème
favorable pour que le médecin s'y
sentent bien
alors il y avait les aides de la région
polybe une cour de ferme en 2018 le
département annoncé financer la
formation 200 maîtres de stage
universitaire sur une durée de trois ans
on parlait justement de ces étudiants
apprécient petit de territoire en quoi
cette aide peut les faire rester
là c'est ce que me disait madame à de
l'ami on avait tout à fait le même le
même souci et à notre grande crainte
c'était c'était de se retrouver avec des
maisons vides et pas médecin à
l'intérieur donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment on travaille en lien avec les
maires dans une démarche tout à fait
partenariale à erez du rps tous les
acteurs de la santé du territoire sont
associés
et on a mené plusieurs consultations
avant de se lancer dans ce programme
d'investissement donc ce sont je le
disais tout à l'heure sont 22 structures
et sortent de terre
qui sont en train ou qui vont
on a investi 32 millions d'euros sur
trois ans pour ceux pour ce plan
d'action départemental
et
attirer les médecins ça en fait partie
donc là on a la formation maître de
stage on allait de secrétariat et on a
aussi alors c'est ça vaut pas pour
toutes les maisons mais parfois quand on
peut quand la structure s'y prête quand
on peut le prévoir dans les travaux ont
fait en sorte qu'ils aient un espace un
un petit appartement pour accueillir un
stagiaire au sein de la maison médicale
ou dans le village si le village à
un local à à mettre à disposition parce
qu'en fait la grosse difficulté dans nos
zones rurales au delà du problème de la
pénurie de médecins c'est de venir s'y
installer quand on est jeune c'est qu'il
faut une voiture on n'a pas forcément
accès partout au transport en commun le
foncier parfois est trop cher pour un
jeune médecin et ce sont tous ces
handicaps qui font qu'on a du mal à
attirer les médecins donc c'est pas tout
avoir un bon maillage de maison médicale
c'est une bonne chose et c'est
extrêmement utile mais il faut qu'on
réussisse à faire venir à maintenir les
médecins en place avec les maisons on
arrive mais il faut qu'on réussisse à
attirer des nouveaux médecins et des
jeunes médecins en sachant que le profil
du médecin aujourd'hui a beaucoup changé
ça a été rappelé au début de l'émission
par un de vos invités et et qu'on est
plus dans le profil du médecin qui vient
s'installer et qui fait toute sa
carrière sur le même territoire il ya
beaucoup plus de turnover qu'avant donc
ça c'est aussi quelque chose à prendre
en compte donc on travaille en lien avec
la faculté et on travaille avec la voilà
sur ces problématiques la
tonsure notamment le changement de
profil des médecins l'agglomération a
fait aussi le choix d'aider les communes
au montage de dossiers
de santé c'est beaucoup d'administratif
oui c'est beaucoup d'administratif nuit
là on rejoint un petit peu ce qui a été
décrit ces savez probablement nous avons
trois msp sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines la première ayant vu
le jour à guyancourt mais dans des
locaux qui appartenait avec lui
appartiennent toujours d'ailleurs à
saint quentin en yvelines et puis la
dernière en date celle de montigny avec
sa spécificité universitaire et moi je
crois pour avoir rencontré les médecins
et les maires je crois beaucoup à ce
lien entre le tuteur de stage et le
stagiaire externe ou interne parce que
on s'aperçoit que c'est un levier assez
puissant pour maintenir les médecins qui
se forment à l'université pour rester
dans le sur le territoire et je ne peux
qu'acquiescer également sur le fait
qu'il faut qu'on fasse très attention
tout cela n'est pas qu'une affaire de 2
millions et de beaucoup de millions
comme ça a été appelé par les détails
par madame la vice présidente de région
mais on doit vraiment aller sur la
dentelle c'est à dire que les médecins
nous disent actuellement et ça rejoint
ce qui vient d'être dit c'est qu'un
médecin va avoir un bébé il aura donc
besoin d'une place en crèche un médecin
va avoir envie de sortir avec ses amis
et il doit donc trouver ces lieux de
convivialité aussi pas trop loin d'eux
de l'endroit où ils travaillent c'est à
tout ça aussi qu'il faut penser je vais
m'adresser au maire de guyancourt dont
vous avez la msp sur votre territoire
cinquante ans mais pas une zone rurale
nous avons quand même trois lignes qui
arrive en médecine est ce que vous êtes
aussi en tant que maire au courant de
toutes les aides qui peuvent être
disponibles à et récents donnent elles
aussi
alors on essaye c'est pas forcément
évident les communes et toutes les
communes ne sont pas forcément
structurés de la même manière pour
pouvoir avoir accès à ces informations
là je pense que sur une ville comme lui
en course est très probablement le cas
je pense aussi que les 18 mois que nous
venons de passer nous ont montré qu'il
fallait peut-être pas voir encore une
vigilance encore accrue sur cette
question de la santé voilà et pas
simplement de la santé en termes de
moyens pour guérir mais aussi de
travailler beaucoup la prévention
l'autonomie le maintien à domicile qui
sont aussi des sujets qui nous
intéressent beaucoup à 51 min
paulino pour le faire est ce que c'est
sur ces maisons de santé ce sont les
collectivités qui se sont rapprochés de
vous est ce qu'il y a eu aussi des
ciblages par rapport aux cartes dont on
parlait tout à l'heure de la rs
une autre dispositif qui s'adressait en
priorité aux zones rurales et aux
quartiers politique de la ville qui sont
les plus en souffrance par rapport à
cette problématique
mais après bien sûr c'est un travail
partenarial avec les maires ou les
présidents d'interco
ce que l'idée c'est pas d'en construire
partout c'est qu'il ya un maillage
cohérent du territoire en matière de
deux maisons de santé par rapport à la
pénurie de médecins qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une cohérence et voilà c'est pas le
tout d'avoir des structures encore
faut-il qu'elle soit utile accessible
bien situé et c mais
bien souvent les maires présidents
d'interconnexion tact est bien
évidemment mais encore une fois on s'est
pas lancé dans des projets s'il n'y
avait pas un des médecins généralistes
d'associer dès le démarrage du projet
voilà on n'a jamais voulu prendre le
risque de se retrouver avec une maison
vide elles sont ce sont des structures
qui restent fragiles qui sont compliqués
à remplir en raison de la pénurie de
médecins eu de la difficulté à recruter
des médecins et mai mais évidemment
c'est une démarche en partenariat avec
les élus locaux
supportant de on avait échangé un petit
peu avant cette émission ainsi que les
faits pour le moment est peut-être un
petit peu perverse était que c'était des
médecins libéraux en cabinet privé qui
se rendaient dans les maisons de santé
est-ce que ça risque finalement d'être
le cas dans toutes les maisons de santé
ou au bout d'un moment la sortie des
jeunes et la fin du numerus clausus
pourrait faire pencher la balance alors
on espère trouver des nouveaux leviers
mais c'est vrai que vous avez raison on
a pu observer au démarrage en tout cas
ce type de phénomène la maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire de lui en cours a
accueilli avant tout des médecins
généralistes qui étaient déjà présentes
sur le territoire de guyancourt donc on
n'a pas augmenté l'offre de soins de la
même manière et j'en discute souvent
avec mon collègue maire de montigny
certains médecins de guyancourt ont
traversé la route pour se rendre à la
dernière en date c'est à dire la msp eu
de montigny ça n'a pas augmenté non plus
ça n'a fait que enlever deux médecins de
guyancourt pour les transférer sur
montigny donc pour l'instant alors après
il ya des leviers vous les avez cité je
vais pas y revenir donc on va améliorer
ça mais pour l'instant c'est encore une
fois les msp c'est un outil absolument
nécessaire voilà on est on est sur du
dur c'est important et il faut
probablement
continuer à les développer mais ça n'est
pas suffisant
je vous propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces
mots c'est la fin de cette société a un
peu particulier toutes nos excuses pour
cette modification notamment deux
plateaux merci aux 1 vitesse est rendu
disponible on se retrouve nos la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau moment
d'échangé de discussion et surtout d'ici
là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
m